are you saying that conor was better in
person or worse in front
of conor in person yeah
what do you think about me online you
thought was an [ __ ] no i didn't i i
didn't even know who you were wow
emily introduced you to me uh yeah emily
you and emily were like friends from the
beginning and emily told you he was a
cool guy and like he and i was like oh
sweet and then when you talk to me it's
like sweet butter in my ears dude
like these emotions like this is very
nice
actually there's a story at the [ __ ]
party
i i was with a bunch of friends yeah and
i was like drunk yeah of course
the emily got too drunk and then she
ended up like throwing up like outside
yeah all my friends ditched me because i
went to the bathroom yeah and i came out
and i was like to poop
no no
[Laughter]
i was peeing okay but i went out and
like i was like where'd the where's all
my friends go yeah and so then i was
like i was like i guess i'll force
myself to like mingle with the anime
tubers which were you guys and that's
when like this drunk [ __ ] like comes
over
yeah
yeah and then yeah that was my
experience i got ditched so i was like
forced to like
just go around
yeah basically
was like my drinking buddy i kept trying
to get him drunk i was like yeah right
yeah i'm not kind of junk like
i wanna buy a drink yeah yeah yeah it
was fun
[Laughter]
know about sorry i got like windows 98
products
i was like how do i compliment again
awesome
that's a positive conventions are just
like fun vibes man like everyone's made
an effort to come out yeah yeah yeah i
was looking for a good time that's very
it's just like everyone's in their like
best mood hopefully
um yeah normally it's
super great i'm normally intoxicated
because
yeah yeah yeah yeah because i remember i
felt so bad because when you came here
and i was just like oh nice to finally
meet you and i was like oh we've met
before i was like oh we have
god karma at the at the party was just
here's his beer he's just like this
call
i was just like trying my best to like
look sober even though i was just like
i'm dying inside man
i think god had hit that you know that
point where you're so drunk where you
just look sober
no no no no i
i was at that point of drunkness where i
was just like existing and like
i'm just like what is going on right now
man his brain was
yeah i barely remember the [ __ ] party
that yeah i'm going to be honest
um well yeah i was like [ __ ] it's
good to have you here like what's how we
can interact in the flesh again yeah
yeah yeah finally i have friends again
yeah i lost all my friends in uh
in the in the states yeah
so you like completely settled in now uh
like mauricio
yeah the murray show where they're like
you are not the father yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i wasn't i wasn't the one that
that cheated but i was in a group
right like one cheated on the others
and then there's a kid involved and i
had to like i had to leave the group i
was like oh this sucks because i've
known these guys for my whole life yeah
and all of a sudden this the murray show
hits me and yeah
well [ __ ] i just lost all my friends
[ __ ] oh damn
you know like where there's like a chair
what kind of stories
two
people just
did
not very
good things yeah yeah
and i'm like i
i can't do this anymore i i i'm like i
told them i'm like wait i'm gonna have
to cut it off yeah yeah oh i'm leaving
this thing
so that kind of made my like my basement
dwelling even more intense right right
right okay okay that was like i don't
know like three years ago or something
right oh was that long ago three years
that was like before coving
you told me this story previously yeah
yeah but i thought it was recent i
thought it was wrong yeah i thought i
thought it was just like happened during
covid yeah and it just like made yeah it
just made your isolation even worse
during covert i didn't realize it was
like even just before covert well my
friends they're all like gamers like
back in the states so we never hung out
like ever
oh okay and i do be like hey you wanna
go with it yeah i could tell they kind
of don't want to they just rather stay
and play the game yeah yeah which is
fine but you know this but here it's
like now i'm like oh hang out yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm like all right let's go
yeah watch this shitty movie called uh
was that [ __ ] movie doctor strange dr
strange and the multiverse whatever the
movie was garbage oh my god
are you totally settled down now in your
new place then is you still built are
you still building furniture like you
were last time we have like one or two
uh furnitures to build it never ends
honestly it never ends well i thought i
would move in like and then within a
week i'd be like working yeah but like i
moved in and gotta get this gotta do
this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you gotta get your residence like you
had to go to the what was that residence
i call it like office
what did you call it it was like
resident something oh the residence
certificate right yeah yeah or like
residence card resident office no
resident you got to tell them it reminds
me of the
the dmv like you
people think i'm japanese so then
they'll like try to speak japanese to me
and i'm like
that's the next dusty yeah yeah
it gets a lot easier like ever since i
moved i've only been to the ward office
once
i rarely have to go yeah it's like
setting up your life here takes a lot of
effort but you're like luckily you're
getting able to get a lot of help and
it's almost done and then once it's set
up it's like so easy it's like freezing
that's made it like very easy yeah yeah
damn thanks man shout out shout out to
you
shout out to us being the beta testers
yeah that definitely helps yeah yeah
what else do you have to do still do you
know are you what else do we have to do
yeah i need a computer chair mailing
i wouldn't chair her is my aunt actually
are you back are you back working enough
cause you're you you like been here
my goddamn wooden chair hurts my ass so
much
you're like a princess yeah
i need my computer
it's my computer gel i need it my omega
chair
this instance
that's good though that you settled in
but like i i you know you're still on
that like
in a furniture building phase yeah i'm
i'm ready to work dude i'm feeling it
has the holiday phase ended because i
remember when i first moved to japan i'm
just like this just feels like a holiday
right now i'm not gonna lie like dude i
might do i really need to work i don't
know it's finally ended because yeah
finally got like you know the sofa yeah
yeah before then we couldn't even like
say anywhere we'd have to lie on the
floor
we we bought these uh what was those
don'ts we don't yeah yeah we slept on
that for like three weeks or something
yeah
going for our bed like and then we had
no couch so when we get up there's like
nowhere to sit you can never rest
and then the only way to rest is your
wooden kitchen chair